NICOLAS GARNIER: Hello, hello
everybody, and welcome to
"What's New with the Google
Drive SDK: One Year Later." My
name is Nicolas.
I'm a developer advocate.
I've been working on Google
Drive pretty much since we
launched Google Drive
about a year ago.
During this session we're going
to have a look at what
happened to the Google Drive
SDK since we launched it,
basically, up until today.
As I said, we launched Google
Drive about a year ago.
And when we launched Google
Drive, we had
several goals in mind.
So of course one of the goals
was to offer to our users a
way to back up all of the
files that are in their
desktop and upload it online
and share their files with
their friends, for example.
So that's pretty much what
people expected from a service
like Google Drive.
But that was actually
not the main goal.
The main goal was really to
make Google Drive a pretty
central place on the
web platform.
And we'll see that
in just a second.
You guys all know now
that the web is
really a platform, right?
You're all using web
apps, for instance.
I know I have moved online for
a lot of my work needs.
For example, I use Google
Sheet, Google Docs--
that's the old name--
Google Slides, pretty
much everyday now.
And there's a lot more than
you can do online.
You can find really nice
image editors online.
I started using, for example,
a online development
environment lately.
You can fax files online.
You can actually listen
to music online.
So my point is, there is now a
lot of very high quality web
apps that you can
find and use.
And we see this trend where
people are really moving away
from the desktop and really
started doing more and more
things online.
As people are really moving
online, they wanted to have a
place to basically keep all
of their files online.
And that's why we launched
Google Drive.
It's really to provide our users
a place to manage and
organize all of the
files online.
But not only that, it's really
also a place for your favorite
web apps to be able to write
files on your Google Drive,
have a place to write and
read files, basically.
That's also why we built Google
Drive, is the case.
It's really to basically
offer the web
platform a file system.
So that that's really important
message here.
Google Drive is really the file
system for the web platform.
And the SDK, it's pretty much
the programmatic interface to
this file system.
So we really wanted to make the
SDK a really easy to use,
easy to integrate
user experience.
So as you'll see, we wanted to
make it pretty much as easy to
integrate as a desktop
application would today
integrate with the local
file system.
We actually didn't want
to stop there.
We wanted to not only make it
as easy for web applications
to use this web file system that
Drive SDK is, but we also
wanted to use some of the
collaboration and security
features that are available on
the web today to make it
basically more powerful and more
secure that if your app
was not on the cloud.
When we launched Google Drive,
of course, what was available
is a programmatic way to access
and manage files.
That's really the API
part of our SDK.
With the Google API, you can
basically do all of the things
that you would expect
from a file system.
You can manage, read,
write file.
You can delete files.
You can create files
on Google Drive.
All that is using a REST API.
It's using also OAuth 2.0 for
our authorization mechanism.
This is all pretty much expected
from the file system
from a data web API that
Google could provide.
One thing that's pretty special,
though, is one of the
security features that we
launched with Google
Drive a year ago.
There's basically a way for
application to restrict
themselves to only gain access
to the files they have either
created or the files that the
user has manually opened
through the drive
user interface.
We'll see how that's possible
in just a second.
And this is actually very, very
convenient for users, right?
Because the application doesn't
gain access to the
entire Google Drive, at least
not programmatically.
They're not restricted to only
a subfolder, like sometimes
it's done here.
The user can potentially open
any of the files that is in
the user's drive with an app,
but without giving the access
to files that potentially you
wouldn't want to give access
to applications out there.
That brings us to the other very
important feature that
was launched with Google
Drive a year ago.
It's the ability for the
application to deeply
integrate with the user
interface, with the user
interface case of the
Drive file export.
Basically, how it works is,
apps can register to
[? append ?] certain
file types.
For example, a user could go in
his drive and try to open
that vacation photo that you
see on the screen here with
PicMonkey or Pixlr Editor.
If you don't know what PicMonkey
or Pixlr Editor is,
these are pretty powerful image
editors that are online,
that you can use online and
that have integrated with
Google Drive.
How it works is, the user is
going to connect his Google
Drive-enabled applications
to Google Drive.
And how he can do that, he can
basically go to his Drive and
directly browse all of the
applications that are Google
Drive compatible that
are available today.
He will simply go to his Create
Menu, click on Connect
More Apps, and he will be able
to browse and search all of
these Google Drive
compatible apps.
There's apps like AutoCAD,
for example.
There are music players.
There are diagramming
applications, photo editors.
There's a lot you can
do right now.
And we're going to have
a look at one of them,
called Hello Fax.
It allows you to do very
easily fax documents.
And they've done a pretty good
job on their Google Drive
integration.
So this is my drive.
There's only a few documents.
And what I want to do is, I
want to fax that PDF here
that's on my screen.
So how I'm going to do
that, is I'm going to
look for Hello Fax.
I simply have to search the
kind of embedded app store
that's inside Google
Drive here.
I'm going to connect
Hello Fax.
And I get a confirmation
dialog.
And then I can do as a user
is right-click, Open With,
select Hello Fax.
Now Hello Fax is part of the
options to open that the type
of file, PDF.
This is the first time I'm
running Hello Fax from Drive.
I get this OAuth 2.0
configuration dialog, just
basically granting Hello Fax
access to my Google Drive.
Now I get redirected
to Hello Fax.
Hello Fax has these
two features.
One is online signature
management feature.
The other one is their faxing
feature, which I want to use.
And as you can see here,
Hello Fax is
pulling my PDF, basically.
It's a very simple,
very small PDF.
It just says Hello.
And that's it.
Hello Fax has my PDF.
I can now use Hello Fax
to fax that PDF.
I could enter any bogus
phone number.
It's going to go to
Austria somewhere.
And that's it.
Hello Fax is actually trying
to send my PDF to
this number I entered.
Hello Fax does a lot more
cool stuff with the
Google Drive API.
For example, they will upload
a confirmation fax to your
Google Drive.
You can also purchase, for
example, phone numbers and
receive all of your faxes
through Hello Fax.
They're going to write all of
those faxes you receive as PDF
inside Google Drive directly.
So there's all pretty
nice features.
When we launched Google Drive
there was 18 partners that
were offering this Deep
UI integration.
And I think you're going to
find about 150 apps today
connectable through
the Google Drive.
There's of course a lot more
applications using the API on
Android, on iOS, and on the
web that are not as deeply
integrated as these 150 apps.
So you can find a lot more.
You can find a lot of
cool applications.
But there's also a lot of room
still left for you to
basically get noticed
inside Google Drive.
So if you're interested in
learning more about this, I
invite you to attend Steven
and Josh's session.
It's called "Getting Your App
Noticed Inside Google Drive."
So they're going to talk about
how, of course, you can get
your app noticed inside Google
Drive, but also how Google
Drive can be an efficient way
to drive traffic or drive
users to your application.
That's at 10:00 AM tomorrow.
We also wanted to allow you to
very easily integrate with
Google Drive.
So we've built basically
a bunch of widgets.
These widgets are common UI
components that you can
integrate very easily inside
your web apps, typically using
a few lines of JavaScript
or a few lines of HTML.
And the first widget that we
launched, actually, when we
launched the API that was
available a year ago, is the
Google Picker.
So the Google Picker is really
a widget that allows your
users to basically browse their
file and select files
inside Google Drive.
That's basically the equivalent
of, if you were on
the desktop application,
starting a file explorer
process to let your users
select a file.
We basically wanted to bring
the same easy integration
experience to web applications
online.
The second widget that was
launched actually at Google
I/O last year, so a bit less
than a year ago, is the
Sharing Dialog.
So it's actually the same exact
sharing dialog that
you're going to find in web
properties like Google Docs,
Google Spreadsheets, or Google
Slides, actually even in
Google Drive.
It's exactly the same UI, except
you're going to be able
to use it inside your website,
embedded inside your website,
and let user share files
directly from your website.
So if you think about it,
that's actually not
so trivial to build.
We have a nice feature like
Autocomplete here.
The widget is also going to look
at if your Google Apps
administrator has enabled public
sharing and display
that option or not.
It's also going to send an email
to the people you've
shared the document with
when you confirm.
So all that is already built for
you and you can integrate
this very easily inside
your website.
I think that's a few lines
of JavaScript.
Also the last widget that we
launched-- that was actually
last week-- is the Safe
to Drive button.
So Safe to Drive button is
pretty simple, right?
It basically allows your users
to download the file directly
to Google Drive instead of
having to download it locally
and maybe re-upload it.
That's all done in basically
one operation.
And what's really nice about
that widget is that it's only
really two lines of HTML.
I'm not kidding.
You copy and paste those two
lines of HTML and it should
work pretty much for most of
the files you could think
about downloading from
your website.
I'm actually going to
show you some of
these widgets in action.
The first app I wanted to show
you is called Neutron Drive.
Neutron Drive is a nice online
ID for Google Drive.
It's nice and integrated
with Google Drive.
Let me switch to
Neutron Drive.
This is Neutron Drive.
As you can see, I'm currently
editing an HTML file in there.
And if I wanted to open a file
that's in my drive, I could
click this button here and
Neutron Drive just pulls up
the Google Picker, where
I could simply
open another file.
What I could do also is, for
example, share that file,
right-click on the tab here
and select Sharing.
You can see that's the
embeddable sharing dialog
that's inside Neutron Drive.
I could just share it with my
friends or my colleagues.
Also the other widget was the
Safe to Drive button.
O'Reilly was one of the launch
partners for that button, so
they had integrated the
button at launch.
That was just a week ago.
And as you can see here, that's
actually one of their
free e-books that you
can download.
And they've added a bunch of
buttons, one for each of the
file formats that you
can download.
Here I'm simply going
to download the PDF.
You have to confirm.
As you can see, the PDF
is downloading.
It's actually a pretty
big PDF.
Once it's done, you can
very simply open it
within Google Drive.
Let me just show you, since it
should take just a second.
As you can see, the PDF
is now in my drive.
And this is our PDF URL.
All right.
One of the features that we
launched that actually got
quite some attention was the
ability for users to basically
publish websites from
Google Drive.
So this feature is actually
pretty simple to use.
Basically, any folder that you
would make public in Google
Drive, the content of the folder
would become directly
accessible through a URL that
you can see here on the
screen, a special URL.
And under that URL, basically,
all of the resources, all of
the files, all of the documents
that would be part
of that folder would be
accessible by path, basically,
just like if they were served
from a regular web server.
Some people did quite some
interesting things with it.
Actually I'm going to go back
to Neutron Drive, who is
actually surfacing that
feature directly from
within their UI.
So Neutron Drive has this
nice file explorer.
It's basically showing all
the files that are
inside my drive here.
And one of the things you can do
is, you can right-click on
a folder and make it web
viewable, they call it.
So that basically makes
the folder public.
Shared publicly.
Once you've done that, you could
simply right-click on
any of the files that are inside
that folder, and click
View Files.
And that's going to open, for
example, that HTML file I was
working on directly as if it was
served from a web server.
That's actually one other
presentation I am sometimes
giving about OAuth 2.0.
So as you can see, that's
HTML5 slides here.
It uses a bunch of service
[INAUDIBLE]
images, et cetera.
So that's all working very
nicely now that it's served
directly from a [INAUDIBLE]
folder.
Let me go back, actually
to Neutron Drive.
Yes, there was one more feature
I wanted to show you
on Neutron Drive here.
Let's say I'm in Neutron Drive
and I'd like to work on the
file with one of my colleagues
named Bob.
Bob's on the right-hand side
of the screen here.
That's Bob's computer.
And I'm on the left.
So what I could do is
very simply share
the file with Bob.
His name is Bob Awesome.
And as I just shared it, you can
see that the file popped
up in his drive.
And he also has Neutron
Drive installed.
So he's going to open that
file with Neutron Drive.
And something very cool
just happened.
The two users--
Anonymous User, that's
pretty strange--
as you can see, those two users
are put in real time
collaboration mode.
Actually, I'm going to reload.
I think there was
a little bug.
It didn't show Anonymous.
OK, well.
It's not the first time a demo
fails at I/O, right?
OK.
And we have some realtime
collaboration
engineers in the room.
Maybe they can do something?
Just kidding.
Well, if things were
working correctly--
actually, it's quite working,
except we have this anonymous
user issue here.
As you can see, the two users
are put in realtime
collaboration mode.
Everything that-- if you
select some text, the
selection is actually shared
and displayed to the user
world, in one direction.
Let's pretend it was working
very nicely.
You could also see what the
other user is typing live.
So that's all pretty much
Google Docs real time
collaboration here.
This very awesome feature--
which would be even more
awesome if it was working nicely
during the demos--
is actually built using one of
the APIs that we launched two
months ago, which is the Google
Drive Realtime API.
So the Google Drive Realtime API
is, as I said, basically
its goal is really to enable
you to build realtime
collaboration features,
to implement realtime
collaboration features in your
web app very easily.
So I've actually used
the API myself.
It's very nice.
It really feels like using
regular JavaScript objects,
except those objects are shared
amongst collaborators.
And the API takes care a lot
of issues for you, like
persistence or conflict
resolution, or, of course, the
broadcasting and delivery of
modifications to all of the
collaborators.
It also does Undo/Redo
presence.
You get the list of people
who have your
document open at the time.
This is a very, very cool API.
It's actually one of the APIs
I'm the most excited about.
It's really advanced web
technology made easy for you.
So, yes, you should really check
it out if your app could
use some realtime collaboration
features, all
makes it really easy for you.
I actually wanted to show you
another app called Draw.io--
we have the founder here
on the third row--
which is a cool diagramming
application that also uses the
Google Drive Realtime API
to implement realtime
collaboration.
So here is Draw.io.
I've actually already shared my
drawing document with Bob,
who is here on the right.
As I drop elements here on the
page, you can see them just
popping up on Bob's computer.
I'm actually really bad at
making these drawings.
And you get very nice visual
cues of what the other
collaborators is doing.
You also have this
little chat here.
You can chat with Bob.
Hey, Bob.
Wassup?
So that chat window was actually
implemented using the
Google Drive Realtime API.
So if you think about it, a chat
window could be almost as
simple as a collaborative or
shared list of strings.
Using the realtime API,
that was actually
quite nice to implement.
All right.
That was Draw.io.
If you're interested in learning
more about the Google
Drive Realtime API, you guys
should attend Brian and
Sheryl's talk, which is
at 2:35 PM tomorrow.
Yes, they're in the room.
It's going to be a great talk.
I think they're not only going
to talk about how you can use
the API yourself as a developer,
but they'll talk a
little bit about how
the API works.
So you'll learn about things
like operational transforms
and a lot of different
things like that.
You guys should really check it
out if you're interested.
All right.
So one of the other features
that we launched-- that was
actually a month ago--
it was actually two features.
We really wanted to allow
applications to write data
they have complete
control over.
So let me explain a bit.
So, as you all know,
Google Drive is a
user-managed cloud storage.
That would typically mean that
the user has total control
over the files that are
in his Google Drive.
He could go ahead and read any
of the files, delete or modify
any of the files in his drive.
It's not always the best.
It's not always working
for every use case.
Let's say you have a web
application and you'd like to
write a configuration file
to Google Drive.
Well, you wouldn't really want
the user to go ahead and mess
up that configuration file.
Maybe that would make your
application have some issues
when it loads.
And probably the user doesn't
even want to see that file in
the first place.
He's going to be like, what the
hell is this configuration
file again?
I haven't created that.
Same goes for a web-based
game, for example.
What if a game would want
to Save Game State
to the user's drive.
You wouldn't really want to be
the user to be able to go and
potentially change what's
inside that
Save Game State, right?
The user could go in and like,
change his gold coins for
something, and cheat,
basically.
So it's not always working for
every use case to give total
control to the user.
To mitigate this, we launched
a couple features.
The first one is called
the App Data folder.
The App Data folder is basically
a hidden folder that
is only accessible to
your application.
It's really private
to your app.
The user doesn't even see it.
It's really hidden.
So that really means that the
user cannot see what's inside
that folder, cannot read the
files, cannot go in and modify
these files.
The only thing that the user can
actually see is the amount
of data that your application
is using.
And he sees that inside the
Manage Apps dialog, as you can
see here on the screen,
as an example.
Also, the only action that a
user can take is to wipe
entirely the data.
So he can just basically reset
the data for an app.
Or he could also uninstall
the app.
That would also wipe
the folder.
So that's the App Data folder.
Oh, and by the way,
in Ali's talk--
that's today at 4:25 PM--
called "Using Drive as a Storage
Solution on Android,"
Ali's going to basically explain
how you can use the
App Data folder effectively
on Android.
For example, to save
the state of your
Android app across devices.
That's really something that
developers have wanted to do
for a long time, save
the state of
your app across devices.
You can now do that
through Drive with
the App Data folder.
So if you're interested, you
should really show up at Ali's
talk today.
The second feature that allows
your application to write
basically app that they control
is called the Custom
File Properties.
So Custom File Properties is
basically a way for you to
attach metadata to a file
itself in Google Drive.
There's an option to actually
make that metadata private to
your app so that only your app
can read it and access
it and modify it.
That's actually great for the
use cases where you would
actually have to keep, for
example, a folder or files in
sync with your own system.
You could actually write, for
example, the ID of the file in
your own system and directly
attach that to the
application, make that private
so nobody else can modify it
or read it.
Basically, just like you were
attaching a foreign key to a
Google Drive file.
That's called Custom
File Properties.
That was actually all of the
major features that we
launched this year concerning
Google Drive.
And we're working on a lot more
cool features as well.
One of the next features that
is coming up is called Push
Notifications.
So hopefully, this is coming
very, very soon.
I'm saying that because
I think we also
announced it last year.
So hopefully, this will be
available very, very soon.
Push Notification is really a
way for your application to
get notified when something
changes in the
user's Google Drive.
For example, when the user
modifies a file or adds a new
file or deletes a file in his
drive, you could potentially
be notified by a server
to server call.
So that really solves some
of the issues where--
basically if your application
wanted to know if something
has changed in the user's drive,
they would have to
check, basically poll every five
minutes, let's say, or
every half an hour, or
every day, to see if
something has changed.
Well, now you won't have to
do that anymore with Push
Notifications.
You will, basically, almost in
real time get notified when
something has changed
in the user's drive.
And potentially, then, get
faster notification, take
faster action.
And it's a win-win, because
for us, you also put less
strain, probably,
on our servers.
Instead of polling every five
minutes or every 30 minutes,
you'll just have to wait until
a notification arrives.
There's of course, a lot
more we're working on.
If you'd like to actually be one
of the first to try all of
the new upcoming features, you
should really join our SDK
Early Access Program.
The SDK Early Access Program--
basically all of the features
that we've launched in the
past six months have been
available early to our Early
Access Program members.
For example, the Push
Notification system that I
just talked to you about
is currently
being tested by our--
EAP, we call them--
Early Access Program members.
So if you're interested in Drive
and want to try out some
really cool technology before
they launch and also help us
make those features right, you
should really try and join our
Early Access Program.
For example, the Realtime API
was really one of the features
that really used some good
feedback from our Early Access
Programs members.
And they really made some
features happen.
They really helped us test
the integration.
They helped also show other
developers what can be
potentially done with it.
During the launch announcements
we point to the
apps, show what they
can do with it.
So thanks again to our currently
existing Early
Access Program members.
And if you're interested,
check out our technical
documentation on
developers.google.com and apply.
Conclusion.
So, as you've seen,
we launched Google
Drive a year ago.
Really, our goal was really not
to make it a very simple
data API only.
We really wanted to bring you to
bring a lot more to you, a
simple programmatic access
to your files.
We're bringing some--
we have this nice User Interface
Integration within
our file explorer.
We also have all
these widgets.
We even have Realtime
API now, which is
really, really awesome.
And you should check it out.
That's really groundbreaking.
There is, again, as I said,
a lot more coming up.
So you guys should really look
for what we're doing.
Read our blog.
That's where we do all
the announcements.
And keep building really
cool apps.
Links.
You can find a lot of the links
to the technologies and
integration points that
I've talked about
today during this talk.
If you'd like to sign up to the
Early Access Program, for
example, that's here.
Also, point to all the other
technologies, Realtime API.
You should also go
to all of the
sessions, the related sessions.
Today there is "Using Drive
as the Storage Solution on
Android," by Ali.
And tomorrow there is "Getting
Your App Noticed Inside Google
Drive" and the "Realtime
API Deep Drive" talk.
These two are tomorrow.
All right, that's it.
I'll be happy to answer
questions.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
NICOLAS GARNIER: Question.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Nicolas.
Charlie Wood from Spanning.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Hello.
AUDIENCE: So, you showed
how users can
connect apps to Drive.
Can domain admins do that?
NICOLAS GARNIER: Not yet.
Not yet.
It's really something that
we want domain admins
to be able to do.
So your question is really, can
a domain admin connect an
app for all of the users of his
domain basically in like,
one operation?
It's something we want to do,
something we're working on,
but it's not available
today, unfortunately.
It's coming up.
Any other questions
in the room?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Nicolas.
It's [? Winn ?] from
Smart Technologies.
We're using the Realtime API
to create a collaborative
whiteboarding application
NICOLAS GARNIER: Sorry, what
is your application doing?
AUDIENCE: It's a collaborative
whiteboarding application.
NICOLAS GARNIER: OK,
whiteboarding.
AUDIENCE: So, we're very
impressed with it so far.
However, we're kind of wondering
in terms of storing
data using the shared
[INAUDIBLE] data model, we're
kind of reaching limits in terms
of how much data we can
put in that shared model.
I'm just wondering what type
of practices we should
[INAUDIBLE]
NICOLAS GARNIER: So what is
the limit you're reaching?
Is that the limit per
realtime model?
AUDIENCE: Yes, that's correct.
NICOLAS GARNIER: What's
the limit?
Actually, you have engineers
working on their Google Drive
Realtime APIs, so maybe they
can make that possible.
AUDIENCE: I'm Brian Karens.
I'm an engineer on
the Realtime API.
Right now, we have a roughly
10 megabyte limit.
It's not fixed in stone.
We're actually working to make
it a little more clear.
You'll have insight into exactly
how much data you're
using in the model so you can
understand where you might be
using space and reduce that.
And we're looking at increasing
that limit over
time as performance allows.
But for now, the limit
would be 10 megs.
NICOLAS GARNIER: You have
pretty big whiteboards.
Yes.
Is there any other questions
in the room?
AUDIENCE: My name is Martin.
I have a couple questions.
One is the File Picker
that you released.
It's very useful if
you're looking for
file but not a folder.
NICOLAS GARNIER:
Yeah, we know.
AUDIENCE: I knew you knew.
I wondered if you had
any updates for us.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Yeah, it's
something we've been
requesting.
It's currently being
worked on.
So the issue is that
you cannot--
basically you can browse, and
if you double-click on a
folder, it's just going
to open that folder.
But you cannot select
a folder, per se.
Yeah, we've heard lots of
requests for that feature.
It's being worked on.
I'm not sure exactly when it
will be ready, but definitely
we're working with that.
AUDIENCE: Another related
question is, if we had the
application data folder, the
Custom Metadata, and we wanted
to share that from one user to
another, we've been looking at
something where we were storing
a folder in Drive so
we could use all that sharing.
I used the sharing widget
and shared across.
But then the user or has
to have a file, and
that's kind of ugly.
So I was wondering if you could
advise if there's a way
around sharing files.
NICOLAS GARNIER: So is your
issue, like, when there is a
file inside the Add Data
folder, basically
you can share it.
Is that your current issue?
AUDIENCE: so I hadn't realized
that there was the sharing
widget you already have.
So I haven't played
exactly with that.
But I guess we were putting a
file that was publicly visible
so that users could share the
configuration they've set up
with some people they want
to collaborate with.
Say, here, it's all
set up for you.
Here it is.
But if they could not need to
see that, that'd be great.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Yeah.
In that case, you could--
well, you can, of course, try
to create your own user
interface for sharing.
That's probably what you've
been doing is using
the API that our--
AUDIENCE: Well, we use the file
so that users could use
the existing sharing interface
for the file and just go and
share that level.
But then the user has
to understand
files, and that's risky.
NICOLAS GARNIER:
Yes, it's true.
But what you could probably do
is, instead of using the
Sharing Dialog, which is
really file oriented.
We tell you the user, hey, you
want to share that file?
Who do you want to
share it with?
You could maybe probably build
your own user interface and
provide your own sharing.
Then you don't have to use the
[? world ?] file if you don't
want you to use it.
You could just say, hey, want
to copy that configuration
file that your friend
has shared with you.
And you could actually
share the file or
copy, make a new copy.
That's probably what you
want to do for a
configuration file.
Basically, build your own
sharing UI would probably be
better for you in that sense.
Yeah.
You want to take
the microphone.
Yeah, I think related to App
Data, JDR, our tech lead on
Google Drive, wants to--
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
At the moment, App Data is
completely private on the
theory that it was private
to the app.
We weren't imagining any
scenarios wherein people would
want to share it.
So thank you for surfacing
this important use case.
We'll talk it over as soon as
we're out of here and figure
out how to help out.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Basically,
sharing is disabled for files
that are inside the App Data
folder, if you wanted to use
the App Data folder.
So as I said, what you can
probably do right now if you
want to have something working
right now, is copy that file
to App Data folder of
the other user.
That'd be the only way.
Thanks for your question.
AUDIENCE: Spreadsheets.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Spreadsheets.
Oh, my God.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I don't know if
it's the right forum.
Can we have a more [INAUDIBLE]
maybe some groups or
users [INAUDIBLE]
NICOLAS GARNIER: Sorry,
can you just--
I didn't get your question
entirely.
AUDIENCE: Like a group cannot
change a column value in
[? A or B. ?]
I know a spreadsheet now
has to be shared.
It cannot have a particular
[? section of the ?] log for
some reason.
NICOLAS GARNIER: So you'd
like to share a
spreadsheet with a group.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
NICOLAS GARNIER: An
entire group.
I think that's possible today.
Have you been facing
issues with this?
For a particular column.
I don't--
NICOLAS GARNIER: Oh, you
want to share just a
column with a group.
Well, I'm not a perfect expert
on Google Spreadsheet.
I think you can--
I'm not sure that's--
No, I don't think that's
possible today.
What you can do is, I think
restrict column, like Block
Columns or something.
I'm not a super expert.
So I don't think that's
possible today.
But potentially if you file a
Feature Request and enough
people want the same feature,
we might build it.
I don't think you can basically
share per column.
It's not like sharing
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: So as I understood,
the App Data is [INAUDIBLE]
But can I write app
scripts which can
access that App Data?
NICOLAS GARNIER: Oh,
good question.
Engineering team, can
we access add data
through Apps group?
No, I don't think so because,
through app
script you're not really--
well, actually can we?
That would be an Add Data just
private to app script.
The point with Add Data is
that it's private to an
application.
So you have to use your
application credentials to
really access it.
Throughout App Script, we could
potentially make it available.
I don't know if it's
possible today.
I don't think it is.
JDR will confirm or not.
AUDIENCE: I just pinged the
guy that works on the App
Script integration with Drive to
double check this, but I'm
pretty sure that the way we
work right-- we do use the
same Google Drive API you're
using to access Google Drive
from App Script.
So if it's not possible, it's
only a limitation in the
interface we've designed.
So it is, in principle,
possible.
We may not have the interface
quite ready.
You should attend John McGowan's
talk later today
about App Script integration
with Drive, where he will go
into these topics
in great detail.
And he's the expert on this.
NICOLAS GARNIER: And
you can ask him.
If that was working, I think all
of your App Scripts would
basically share the
same App Data.
Because that would be
seen as the same
application through the API.
That's how it would work.
Is there any other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You have a really
awesome feature of publishing
the HTML from Drive.
Is there any way we can just
have that for Google Apps
users so it could be restricted
to a domain?
NICOLAS GARNIER: I know the team
has been wanting to make
this work with the
Sharing settings.
Right now it only works
for public--
you have to make the public.
I think they were speaking about
also allowing it for
even protected documents so
that you could share, for
example, a folder just
with your domain.
Then the website would only be
available to your domain.
I'm not sure how far they are
with this or if they are still
going to this direction.
I have to double-check.
But that's something they wanted
to do from the start.
It's just harder.
It's harder.
It's all in a sub-domain.
You have to know who's
signed in.
So that's a bit technically
harder .
Any other questions?
All right, well, thank
you, everybody,
for coming and listening.
[APPLAUSE]